and the last time you were here you you
were here to tell us about if bealls
could talk
and then off you went and we saw
honestly i felt like a member of my
family was winning an oscar when i saw
you
opening your mosque congratulations on
your oscars thank you
all of it is such a
blur in a lot of ways you know i just
remember
being there and thinking even though i
know
the order of the awards i'm like this is
happening now i'm first up okay we're
first up
okay and i just looked at my mom like oh
it's happening
and that just it's still surreal and
just i felt so
much love in that room yeah i did i
really did
imagine being one of the other actresses
who had to sit there as a loser for
hours like first stop that's great
like it's a long evening if you don't
win well you know what but then you know
you the pressure's off and they do have
a bar there hello
no one's a loser but now talking to the
bar you took your mother's a date but
she wasn't that interested in all the
amazing
parties and stuff uh no we went to
uh the vanity fair has a big party every
year and
we went and i'm just like oh my mom
she's gonna get to meet more of the
actors and
everyone here and she's like yeah
i don't know why you guys like this
i'm i'm going home
so uh the driver took her home
and then we went to beyonce and jay-z's
parties super fancy party one of the
great things uh about
uh you know for stars is the support of
friends and family
and one of your big supporters is your
uncle willie
yeah uh no you i mean does he do this
for everything because he's really
looking forward to watching it
because he does this for every show for
everything
everything that's my uncle willie man
and you think you think that's nice of
him to do that no he went further
he held last on sunday last sunday he
had a special
viewing party uh
where did he have it he had it in a game
it's a place called game time my uncle
is like the mayor
you know he he if you if you need
something you go to uncle willie
and he just he's so proud of his nieces
my sister and i and he just shouts it
with his heart and with his voice
all the time and you know i wish
everyone could have a uncle willie and i
think a lot of people have their version
of uncle willy
you